c'est sûr que ma mère me prenait pas au
sérieux
personne ne prend au sérieux dans tout
ça dans le sous sol de ses parents bader
chaubard s'activent les cégépiens
observe le cours de différentes crypto
monnaie c'est virtuel ça existe pas dans
que c'est nouveau pour eux
en un clic il étoffe son portfolio avec
un objectif clair derrière la tête
pourquoi ça m'intéresse pas ce que je
veux libre financièrement je veux pas
travaillé toute ma vie avoir des de
toute ma vie je veux vraiment pouvoir
atteindre mes objectifs
c'est grâce aux réseaux sociaux que
bader a commencé à investir sur tik tok
il suit des influenceurs qui se
décrivent comme des coachs en finance je
vais propriété 400 mille dollars parmi
eux le montréalais issa mbaye il y a
deux ans le trentenaire n'était pas du
tout actif sur les réseaux sociaux
pendant la pandémie il commence à filmer
les capsules et s'étonne de leur succès
à chaque fois qu'ils doivent faire un
achat ou une transaction il va récupérer
toutes les économies qui l'a mis en
place mais lorsque j'ai partagé mon
contenu sur type toc et que j'ai pu
l'adapter à la réalité et coutts étaient
explosées pc lock j'ai réalisé à quel
point les gens sont intéressés à
l'information quand je vois ça je pense
à libersa les apps à la liberté
financière tandis que la liberté soit
allumée rallye bercy financière qu'ont
vulgariser la finance ils se demandent
l'aide de sa soeur âgée de 18 ans je
pense que les gens vont être intéressés
comme ça parce que je pense qu on line
des corses à peu trop fort belle et tout
comme plusieurs de ses amis elle a déjà
commencé à acheter ses premières actions
kourissa c'est signe que les jeunes ont
un rapport différent avec
l'investissement on entend toujours
toujours cette même phrase le 9 à 5 ok
prendre sa retraite à 65 ans
mettre de l'argent de côté pour serrer r
je te dirais qu'aujourd'hui ce que nos
parents voulaient ce que l'on vaut
aujourd'hui c'est deux choses
complètement différentes
il ce n'est pas le seul à avoir
identifié et ce nouveau paradigme
sur techtoc ils sont des centaines à
faire des finances personnelles leur
niche pour scripto immobilier placements
et langages la finance n'a jamais été
aussi populaire et oublie pas l'excusé
tech comme marketing média rosario ont
fait aussi partie de ces nouveaux
influenceurs a diplômé en comptabilité a
quitté son emploi dans une banque il y a
deux ans depuis elle vit uniquement de
la création de contenu
par les beautés de sap amassés par
excellence
le nombre d'abonnés de thé dia est en
croissance constante
mais l'engouement n'est pas seulement
virtuelles dans sa vie de tous les jours
aussi la jeune femme le constate et
m'ont pas maintenant
avec des investissements
tout le monde
[Musique]
parce que c'est accessible il est vrai
que l'accès à l'investissement n'a
jamais été aussi facile les applications
comme world impôts permettent d'acheter
des actions en quelques secondes et leur
popularité a grimpé en flèche dans les
deux dernières années la barrière à
l'entrée
nettement moins important qu elle leur
était pour des générations antérieures
le professeur simon des remarques arvois
ce virage d'un bon oeil pour l'expert on
assiste à une démocratisation de la
finance il y a un sentiment
d'appartenance à des communautés il ya
un sentiment de développement des
connaissances dans une industrie dont
plusieurs ignorent carrément son
existence et ça je crois que c'est
quelque chose de positif mais ce qui
m'inquiète c'est le sentiment que faire
de l'argent facile mais les risques sont
nombreux prévient l'autorité des marchés
financiers du québec on est aux prises
avec un marché qui est très volatile il
ya des gens qui vont investir dans le
creux de vague tant mieux mais ceux qui
investissent au sommet de la vague pour
l immense farmer au-delà des risques
associés à la volatilité de certains
investissements le pdg de l'aef
s'inquiète du message propagée par
beaucoup d'influenceurs encore une fois
il ya cette perception là qu'on peut
tout faire seul et puis qu'on est en
mesure de prendre de bonnes décisions
aux seuls je pense l'avenir nous dira
qu' il y en a qui se seront se seront
trompés royalement d'un oui j'ai fait de
l'argent mais j'ai perdu de l'argent
aussi donc la dèche marie conscient de
ces risques lorsqu'il était au
secondaire l'étudiant a perdu 2000
dollars après l'effondrement d'une
crypte où monet la mésaventure ne l'a
cependant pas arrêtée l'appât du gain
est resté trop fort c'est pas la
première fois que j'ai perdu de l'argent
dans ce milieu donc moi je suis habitué
faut pas avoir peur de perdre je sais
pas comment l'expliquer c'est super 2000
$ dans ce milieu pour moi c'est correct
j'ai pas de sentiment
[Musique]
si le cgpi et rêve de vivre un jour de
ces investissements il n'a pas
l'intention d'abandonner les études ou
autant
signe que les promesses de gains rapides
ne font pas disparaître les besoins
immédiats celui de trouver un emploi de
payer ses factures en attendant de
peut-être un jour toucher le gros lot
[Musique]